welcome to this video part 7 of the
world championship pre serious showing
great games by the two participants this
is some again a game by the world
champion Vijay Anand and for this game
were going back to 1995 I'd like to put
this into context a bit the game itself
is great enough but it's just some some
some history here 1995 this was the
candidates final match back then to
decide the Challenger for Kasparov this
was played in the cycle of despair of
alternative organization back then
called the PC a 1993 ad left feeder and
made up his own organization and own
world title so I'm Alan and Kamsky were
competing here in this final they had
won a number of matches beforehand so it
was not some sort of seeded thing they
they beaten beaten some players before
them and qualified in a big tournament
and so on they had a whole cycle and
there's a bit of history in this in this
match also because in 1994 one year ago
Anand and Kamsky also played a match for
the feeder candidates cycle so they
competed in both and back then Chomsky
won the match in India so this is also a
bit relevant if to to this year's match
because this is one thing that always
sticks in your mind if you have no bit
of chess history are not playing at home
he lost this back then very crucial
match despite being maybe a slight
favorite against time scheme he lost at
home so this is also about people
sometimes think that it's a disadvantage
for Ireland to actually play at his
hometown of Chennai in India so this
final decided to the Challenger for
Kasparov
and this was game 9 and Island if I
remember correctly was leading by one
point
so I'm every point counted I think they
played for for 12 games so this game
you're probably guessing already it's a
victory for Vichy so this game basically
was the decider and also I'm an
excellent strategical achievement let's
see what happens
comes keep playing a 5 this was his
principal defense at the time and also
if you think ok coughs Keys playing
still today and after this long break
that he took but I just turned the clock
back he was 21 at the time being in the
world number 3 about the world number 3
he was clearly Kasparov and Karpov
whether that was still the two best
players and behind that there was a
small group of of players that were
about similar in strength and Kamsky
really had a big run at that time he
qualified for this candidates final in
the PCA and got to the title match 4
feet against cup of which he lost in
1996 so Kamsky really a top opponent
he's still great today but back then he
was even higher ranked so we have a way
close to it
this was [ __ ] schism weapon of choice in
this match and he played the Zaitsev
starting with rookie 8 you can also
start this with Bishop d7 it's only a
minor minor difference and back then
this was maybe the main line of the way
influenced by the Kasparov cup of
matches cup of really insisted on
playing this line despite really worse a
really bad results he had some good
positions against Kasparov but it simply
suited his power of star low I guess
yeah black is developing the bishop to
b7 and going for this quick regrouping a
from aged successes all played numerous
times and now he takes d4 the
is the idea let's have a look the night
before attacking the bishop and retreats
and right here we get to the first
important point of this game the
absolute main line and nowadays
basically the the only line that is
played here for black is the move c5
this is continued with d5 97 ok 3 and
then f5 this is the the the main line of
this opening nowadays it also was the
main line back then but nowadays it is
basically established that like should
play this way there's not there's no
serious alternative and today's view and
maybe maybe c4 but ok this f5 and this
also has been played in this Kasparov
cup of matches the cup of quite often
managed to completely tag down whites
Queen side but very often got mated you
see that the king is doesn't have so
many defenders as best pieces on the
Queen side but this is what what black
probably should play Kamsky I played
Queen d7 which was a normal move back
then but it had to had it's a sideline
but it had a pretty decent reputation
but now honored place them please b3
this has a very deep idea we see we see
later 56 so Queen d7 basically delays
the c5 count of counter play and this
not as sharp as this f5 idea there
should be 2 and Bishop to g7 this is all
very normal and here it it starts a
series of really an excellent moves by
by Anand the next move is 7:30
but it's also based on on some concrete
calculation what wide probably is
thinking about if you look at the
position this is a move you would
consider attacking the night and after
c5 you probably don't want to release
the tension you want to play d5 what
really always wants to answer c5 with d5
to show that this is a bad piece on b7
this is just biting on granite and feels
like slightly strange
benoni however there's always tactics
and chess like here can take on any form
and win the game now it's based on this
loose bishop if you take here this 92
and black is simply winning he's winning
upon directly but also d5 is gone so
Bishop c3 doesn't really work I mean it
you can play it but after c5 you don't
you cannot play d5 what you want
Adonis move Queen C 1 it is very strong
it looks at the c5 square so if black
now plays c5 he also has to reckon with
with tactical ideas against those
supports for example after taking Luke
takes Daisy 5 and this gets very tricky
let's say the knight moves and 94 c5 is
not really well-timed at this position
note that this is one key idea c5
therefore is not playable but Kamsky
prepared as he played rook c8 and now
the idea one idea behind quincy one is
really played Bishop c3 so that after c5
you actually can play d5 now this Bishop
is covered so 94-94 is just
it's just not working at all and now
this is a very interesting position and
something you you should look at yeah
with the take take a bit of time to
understand this this type of position is
I back then was very impressed by this
concept the bishop on c3 it's always
looking at this Knight and sort of
putting some pressure on this piece and
what this means is as long as this
Bishop is on c3 black can never ever
play c4 what he probably wants to do try
to advance his majority he's got this
three pawns against two and you
naturally want to advance it but as long
as you've got this configuration of this
bishop against the night there's no way
you ever can play see form and and look
at this this night it doesn't have a
square it's um it looks nice on before
what but what is actually doing it's a
ticking nothing and it has no square to
go to so this is an interesting
phenomenon where you have a piece on an
outwardly good-looking position but it's
not doing much and back then the Sun
really impressed me and I always had
some yeah second thoughts about the move
a formed in lots of positions of queen
pawn openings in the beam only you play
a four and give up the before square and
never I really like to do that but this
game really was a great example that
very often this is only a good-looking
post but it's not doing so much okay
let's see um how it continues tom scheme
now plays Queen to e7
and Alan tonight f1 yeah this is typical
regrouping you go to e3 or g3 in this
case probably III and now comes to play
tonight
h7 this move was criticized back in the
bag at the time when the game was played
I'm not so sure really it's probably not
especially great but it doesn't seem to
be a big problem
back then they suggested to go 97 and
this indeed makes some sense if you look
at it in context with Queen e7 if you
play Queen d7 it looks like you prepare
97 I'm not quite sure maybe he was
irritated by this kind of business but
it's not clear that why did she so much
with this not clear they played night h7
but it's um it's probably a better than
it was thought back back in the day
King g7 and 93 this is getting this idea
into the mix and so see force of course
not not possible you can take and you
have this this check coming note that
the instant Chinese III okay we can get
95 I thought community of six would get
this counter play but this is also
winning so in Quincy's we also possible
so c4 is still not on and I think here
in fact Chomsky is committing the the
real mistake of the game he he this is
one of those games where you have a hard
time to pinpoint the losers mistake
sometimes it is it's rather obvious or
you can at least in her with hindsight
it's obvious if it chess is difficult
you need some time to figure it out but
sometimes you can we say okay this was
the point where at all
wrong and probably here this is the
point at age five and I had to have had
a fresh look at this game with Auto with
the help of the computer and I was
pretty stunned by the computer
suggestion here Houdini suggestion
computer gave look a eight with equality
and I was very sure that this is one of
those cases where the computer doesn't
understand the position it it sometimes
really still happens that you that you
get those kind of evaluations that are
simply not true but the computer has
some point it's at least much much
tougher than then the game the idea oh
this is that ninety four isn't the real
threat black can play h5 then and you
can you can give this check if you like
but it doesn't really it doesn't really
fit well with whites plants so this is
not really a threat and what should why
do I thought the natural move is
actually Queen d2 which whoops sorry
so okay it and then Queen d2
look eight and then Queen d2 this is
what I thought is the natural move so
the Queen takes up this role of the
bishop with attacking the knight so
let's see force never on but here black
has gotten IG five and this is a key
difference to the game where h5 had
weakened the g5 square so energy fight
was not possible and in fact this kind
of position I still think that white is
a bit better but it's it's much much
tougher than the game the computer has a
point Yemen the thing is that white is
still like white but it's not so
clear-cut um if white those four ninety
one two three c3
there's some problem with this for
example so this is much tougher
I still like white but it's not it's not
so clear as in the game but gave me
played h5 and now Queen d2 this idea I
already had shown and the problem is now
if you if you compare this and let's say
okay why not not g5 then the problem is
simply that okay this wins the Queen g5
is weakened you cannot take with the
column on h6 anymore so this is no
counter play and what what should like
do he played a thing to g8 probably
probably a decent defense and now comes
to the next the next great concept to
convey five and now you you might think
all right okay seven but it's it's not
really leading to much just get the
routes exchanged it's not helping at all
but I found a great way to improve this
position and this is in a way based on
the fact on the concept to check which
pieces really still have a useful role
or which pieces are according to the
last couple of moves with speed which
pieces are maybe not optimally place and
he played the very strong move 91 those
retreats are always impressive I think
if you play in and retreat with in with
aggressive intentions
alright simply you saw that those
squares that the knight is looking at
here I controlled
g6 and h5 you you won't get the Knight
to f5 as a sacrifice or something so he
reboots the night and puts it on c3
where this ideally placed and the text
the b5 weakness it also saw attacks on
canvas
efore and d5 so it's a very harmonious
setup and yeah p5 is a weakness this
point is unprotected and the night is on
its way to attack it Knight a6 not a
move that you like to play but how else
to to protect the Queen side it's very
very difficult black could have tried
something else but it's also very very
tricky let's say something like this you
could you could drive but you still have
this problem that you let counter play
and getting the Queen over to the Queen
side always looks very dangerous due to
this Queen h6 ideas so white can really
think think of switching attention back
to the to the Kings side it's difficult
to cover the point
so Kamsky decided to to advance it right
back to a 693 and B form yeah White has
a good square now and b5 and she flatly
takes up this invitation to to an
advance the night
there also was night a form also not a
better bet moves the ideas Knight b6 to
see for the night on c4 so would be an
excellent piece but Knight d5 is strong
no doubt about that
Knight c7 this was comes his idea
exchanging his unlucky night but Bishop
e3 simply and we have this trade look at
the end now we see that we have this
typical case of a frozen pawn majority
it's two against one
but this is never ever going to to
happen and what makes it very strong
simple and good move Bishop c4 those
little moves are important it blocks
this once and for all
it covers d5 so that you can play e5 at
a later stage and imagine a sequence of
moves
once again without the arrows like a 5d
takes and d6 this breakthrough and this
puts the bishop right into the right
diagonal now with the Queen on h6 you
have Queen snakes g6 this kind of ideas
are already in your mind in this
position so Bishop c4 is a simple and
strong move Knight f6 and here it's the
only spot where you might criticize that
they criticize the wrong word but where
you can substantially improve with
computer help on allens play otherwise
this is a completely flawless game here
it seems that while his move retains and
practically decisive advantage she 85
just went straight away but maybe it's
move 32 and it's been complicated this
game maybe it didn't have much time this
seems to win straight away but it's
something typical for a computer this
direct technical solution with d6 coming
that's this point also if v seems to win
straight away but smoothness is not bad
at all Queen h6 as I mentioned it
introduces this leaf I've de d6 idea
with comintex g6 so black feels
compelled to get rid of the Queen Queen
f8 and then Queen back to g5 keeping the
pressure on community 7 and rook a7 and
this is also winning I mean if I was
just the more brutal move but if I have
on move 32 but this is also very strong
black really has no way to defend the
see play group c7 and now Bishop a6
setting up the pin here look b8 and now
everything is nicely positioned
and here we go this brief breakthrough
only has been delayed and um yeah it's
it's it's gone after the capture there's
v6 Ruby seven and ninety five and black
falls apart he played you create okay
898 also this move also do this because
you will lose one piece at least so back
to here to e8 and now we have a simple
way to convert the advantage Queen
appears on d8 and sets up at this pin
between two f8 and look a one and this
is basically the end of it that's Luke
aah this threat is very strong 97 they
only moved to yet to really who's that
you can play without Chris signing Queen
to t7 this idea this idea
it's all very tangled up Queen b8 the
only move
and now just Queen xt6 and yeah the rest
is a matter of some precision but we get
to the point where you don't need to be
a vegetable to win this v3 so black
pushes this point and aspiration but
white can simply transfer the Queen and
with 95 and Queen a form cover this
important square and attack on f7 at the
same time so f6 and here why just
captured 95 the last last try you know
f7 check and the F pawn just decides if
you see
something like this check this check
this is a very easy win with with me to
come check continue till the end and
commune g7 is unavoidable so I'm this is
a game that I really like it it's it's
just perfect strategy at work
this kind of idea with pressurizing this
this night and it's repeated again and
therefore freezing up the Queen side has
really impressed me and this has been
seen numerous times even after the game
so you see that studying those those
games can be really helpful this is
something that from next point of view
really looks attractive but if you check
it in more detail and look at the
concrete concrete lines so you see that
this only looks good it's not really
helping black to have this this nylon
before yeah I hope you like the game I
think it's it's a great strategical
achievement and yeah I'll be back
tomorrow with with yet another episode
of this series thanks for watching